let's talk about how one would put their
autoimmune disease into remission of
course we can't say cure but we can say
remission it's called spontaneous
remission I've done a lot of videos on
autoimmune diseases but I recently found
some fascinating new information I want
to share with you because if you have an
autoimmune disease and you want to put
in remission you need all the data you
need to know this one very important
fact there's been some recent research
finding a huge link between this virus
Epstein-Barr virus and many of the
autoimmune diseases now
here's the thing you might say well this
doesn't apply to me well guess what 90
of the population
has had Epstein-Barr virus but here's
the thing the unique thing about the
Epstein-Barr virus that's different from
a lot of other viruses it can go in the
remission okay it can kind of go away
and it can also come out of remission in
other words it goes in this dormancy
state where it just kind of sits there
and waits for the right environment and
see normally when your immune system
is exposed to a virus
your immune system fights it off it
develops antibodies and now it's it has
an immunity against that virus but the
Epstein-Barr virus is different
Epstein-Barr virus has this ability to
infect certain immune cells
and actually reprogram them and alter
their function you see normally it's
really our own proteins that can turn on
or turn off certain genes but with this
Epstein-Barr virus
it can actually bypass that and alter
our genes unfortunately so it makes this
protein which can bind and control your
genes and actually trigger autoimmune
diseases if the right environment occurs
let me explain what I mean by that when
we're talking about autoimmune diseases
there's a certain immune cell called the
T helper cell 17 that's always involved
in autoimmune diseases and without
trying to get into the details of that
all you need to know is that this cell
can either protect you against
autoimmune diseases or creating
situation where it can cause an
autoimmune disease with how it deals
with inflammation and whether it
protects you or harms you it really
depends on the environment of that T
Cell the environment which is really
related to your epigenetics so this
explains why some people develop
autoimmune diseases and some people
don't even know
they're exposed to Epstein-Barr virus
like I said before 90 of the population
has been exposed to Epstein-Barr virus
it is one of the most common viruses
that we're exposed to so we are going to
talk about how to create an environment
to bulletproof yourself and keep these
autoimmune diseases in remission it's
called the kissing disease okay this is
why probably a lot of people get it in
high school it can create what's called
infectious manuculosis which affects
your lymph nodes your throat a fever it
can be really nasty I had it in high
school of course after kissing someone
and it it was just devastating it
literally couldn't breathe and I think
it lasted for two weeks and it was
terrible
but it's not highly contagious okay but
it does spread through saliva blood
semen and it's also a herpes virus for
and like I said before it can stay
dormant for years and never come out of
remission or it can come out of
remission when you have this perfect
storm which I want to discuss right now
so this is the environment right so
the reason why certain people get in
other people don't it really has to do
with um their own Integrity the
resistance to fight this thing off how
strong their immune system is and then
how great the external stress is as well
so stress has a lot to do with the
triggering effect
uh because the high level of cortisol
can paralyze the immune system one of
the biggest stresses out of all the
stresses is bereavement which is a loss
in your grieving after a major loss so
the greater the loss the more the stress
the more it can trigger an autoimmune
disease and I've talked about this in
other videos in fact it's like one for
one my patients they developed an
autoimmune disease after a stress event
so we have stress we also have another
interesting uh thing that can happen gut
radiation so let's say you had radiation
of your abdomen or a CAT scan that can
alter your microbiome and create
dysbiosis and set you up for an
autoimmune disease let's say for example
you had an antibiotic it can create
dysbiosis and that can also be a trigger
or let's say you consume a lot of foods
with glyphosate like in GMO foods that
can alter your gut microbiomes and then
set you up for having this autoimmune
disease especially if you had
Epstein-Barr virus in the past and also
nutritional factors let's say you're low
in vitamin D or zinc and then you go
through through a stress event right
you're going to be very vulnerable to
developing one of these conditions
there's also certain drugs there's also
steroids there's even the stress of
pregnancy that can set you up for an
autoimmune disease what's interesting
and unique about a pregnancy is that
there are certain autoimmune diseases
that go in remission once you're
pregnant and then they when you're done
being pregnant then they can come out
but there are certain autoimmune
diseases that can be triggered by
pregnancy as well now there also are
other triggers that I can't really
mention in this video but I have
mentioned them
you know indirectly in other videos
which I'll put a link down below that
can set you up for this perfect storm to
develop an autoimmune disease
but let's just dive into what to do to
put this autoimmune disease into
emission permanently so here's the plan
we don't want to just focus on
inflammation and the autoimmune disease
we want to focus on this Epstein-Barr
virus okay because this is new
information because if we can just like
let's say assume that that that's
involved then we have a different
strategy and we can focus in on
something that can actually greatly help
you so we want to put this Epstein-Barr
virus back into remission and one of the
best ways to do it is to of course drop
your stress level as much as possible
isolate exactly what's really stressing
you out and do whatever you can to
minimize that stress at least lower it
that's going to help there's a test
called an HRV test heart rate
variability test heart math is an app in
a device that you can get to measure
heart rate variability and the reason I
like this test is it measures the
parasympathetic
nervous system and the sympathetic
nervous system it'll give you data about
this information and tell you how much
parasympathetic you have which is your
recovery versus how much sympathetic
which is your stress
and it's very interesting because some
people might not even feel that they're
in sympathetic dominant but they were
and they have basically no
parasympathetic and they're more at risk
for having their immune system lowered
to Poland virus so this is a good test
to just give you feedback to know where
you're at and I will put a link down
below of heart math if you wanted to get
one of those now some other things to
help lower the stress and to put this
Epstein-Barr virus back into
where it needs to belong is about in B1
a good amount of B1 is very very
important potassium and magnesium vital
and vitamin D and in high doses at least
40 000 IUS
that's going to take inflammation away
and it's also going to help put this
Epstein-Barr virus back in remission if
you also add a good amount of zinc I
would take no less than 50 milligrams of
zinc every day so these are the two most
important things to to take aerobic
exercise versus other types of exercise
aerobic exercise gives you a lot of
oxygen it helps lower cortisol which
will put more control in your immune
system so long walks
you know a bike ride that is not too
intense
very very important all right number two
handle dysbiosis so the gut very very
key since 80 of your immune system is in
your gut so you need to start taking
probiotics as well as fermented uh
vegetables but if you're going to take
probiotics start small because if you
have dysbiosis you can create an immune
reaction so
if you're taking it in liquid form take
a very small amount and a teaspoon if
you're taking in a capsule take half of
a capsule because I made a mistake when
I had a lot of problems with gut issues
to take the regular amount and I ended
up with a major detox or number three
you should do a 48 hour fast every two
weeks on a regular basis if you did that
for two to three months that alone will
help not just to lower inflammation
which is going to do
but also to strengthen greatly your
immune system which is exactly what we
need to do to put this thing back in
remission it can only really come out if
there's a weakness
all right number four
decrease inflammation through fasting
vitamin D as well as omega-3 fatty acids
and also getting off carbs so do the
ketogenic diet ketones are natural
anti-inflammatory compounds and lastly
number five for those of you that have
stuck around this long which you're
smart because this one's a very
important one pmgs now what is a PMG
protomorphogen what's a protomorphogen
well as a company I'm not affiliated
with them anymore but standard process
is a nutritional company that sells it's
called pngs and they have different uh
nutritional products that have glandular
extracts like over 12 and PMG they have
them for the thyroid they have them for
the lung tissue they have them for the
liver tissue so they have PMG products
for pretty much every tissue that's in
your body and what's interesting about
these PMG is that it's it's a dehydrated
DNA of an animal and even though it's
from a different species you can still
use this as a strategy okay and this is
how it works let's say you had for
example Hashimoto's
that's of your thyroid gland you have
antibodies that are attacking your own
thyroid gland
okay you would take
their product for the thyroid because it
has the pmgs in it and you would take
one before a bed and what's going to
happen when you take it before bed it's
going to go into the stomach and the
antibodies are going to attack
that Decoy and leave your thought right
alone okay and then the next night you
would do it again next night you would
do it again and you do that for about
three months
so whatever type of autoimmune disease
you have whether Ms which is in the
brain which is neurotrophin PMG or you
have type 1 diabetes which is antibodies
against your own pancreas in that case
you would take pancreotrophin PMG so
this is the Little X Factor the
additional strategy that you could also
try and you'll have to do your own
research to find out where you can buy
these pmgs I think you can pretty much
get all of them online right now or find
a practitioner that uses standard
processed products in your area now
another really good video for you to
watch especially because we're talking
about viruses
is my video on zinc check it out I put
it right here